[Music]
bill o'brien has done great things with
the houston texans but in the wake of
yesterday's meltdown against the kansas
city chiefs some of the columnists in
houston calling for o'brien to go look i
mean chris there are plenty of teams out
there that would love to get to the
round of eight and lose i mean it's all
relative
i just i i know he's got a lot of juice
there now there's no gm
he's fiery uh there was a time where the
thought was he wanted to leave houston
you know when he was in that battle with
rick smith that power struggle and now
bill o'brien has won it but you know at
some point
and this is the danger of getting close
too often it's almost like what happened
with john fox in denver
you you can't tantalize ownership in the
fan base by getting close it people get
frustrated people run out of patience
and there may be some thought in houston
that that's starting to happen yeah well
it seems like it but that's insane like
houston you got a problem like chill the
hell out i don't know what your thing
never heard that one before yeah well
yeah you heard it again i mean chill out
he's one of the he's one of the better
head coaches in all of football there's
come on houston he got he brought the
team to the playoffs with a bunch of
quarterbacks where i would go you know
they're borderline third stringers i
mean he did that it's only a second year
with desean watson i understand it's
desean watson's third year before we you
know first year yeah towards acl okay
these last two years they've gone to the
playoffs they made progress this year
they won a playoff game with desean
watson you know is it perfect down there
you know do i agree with every personnel
decision he's made no okay but man he's
made them relevant they're they're in
the nfc
afc south battle and the champs more
years than not
and you know his teams are tough and
they play tough and they just need a few
other moves on their roster to help them
out but they're going in the right
direction once again too they've gotten
the offensive line a little solidified
you know they got a lot of good things
there they need some more players on
defense some more difference makers on
you know the defensive line things like
that but
i think houston better be careful what
they wish for right there this is one of
the better coaches in the game i
wouldn't want you know you're you're
playing the what-if game oh what if this
guy comes in what if you got next guy
that comes in not a damn good coach then
your team's going to fall off billy oh
is a really good coach i i don't agree
with that
the argument i guess would be with
deshaun watson there you could attract
an a-list coach from somewhere else but
i i don't know that i buy it i just you
know there is frustration when you get
close enough times fans want more
ownership wants more and here's the
thing too
i agree with you o'brien should stay but
i think they do need to hire a general
manager i don't like the idea of going
forward with o'brien basically running
things and others helping set the table
you need a voice in there to counter
o'brien's personality and most coaches
have big personalities strong
personalities they want things their way
they'll fight no and they'll argue and
you need someone who can stand toe to
toe and face to face right and and push
back when need be in the best interest
of the team and uh i i think that it's a
mistake to not have a general manager
well i i think he agrees with you right
i mean he wanted nick casario we know
that i think he's all for like an hour
now his contract's going to explode yeah
well i mean maybe we'll see a move like
that here real soon i i don't think he's
anti-gm or anything like that i just
think he wants a guy that kind of sees
eye to eye to the way he wants things
done and build a team i don't think he
has any problem with it i don't know
that for sure but i mean just all signs
point to that he has worked with a gm
two of them you know yeah hasn't been
perfect i think the first gm there that
yeah wasn't maybe doing things the way
he would have liked uh but i i think
this is a guy that is a good football a
really good football coach team is
always tough you know situationally
usually really good that way too yeah i
didn't like the fake punt call yesterday
but okay i mean it's you know you make
mistakes and he had his reasoning it's
not like he's just some idiot who just
called it i mean he's a smart
well-thought-out guy so i hear you with
the gm stuff and i think they probably
will get somebody there but i think
billy oh is one of the better coaches in
football and he would be one of those
guys that yes if you fired him he would
get hired immediately he would buy an
opening i know it's not going to happen
this year all the jobs are filled but
you know if a year where jobs were open
somebody's going to get billy oh he's
already proven that he's a worthy head
coach
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports